this is gonna be my uh
my like
fifth attempt on of playing title
tuesday
i just so happen to be to be streaming
it this time
but yeah let's see let's see how it goes
let us do it
so we have queen's gambit in decline it
seems
bishop e7 okay so now that f6 i'm going
to play
a sideline queen c2 now c5 is probably
the uh the easiest to equalize but my
opponent does not go for it that's fine
yeah this is also fine
and here the the idea is that yes it is
the castle one and cast along and try to
checkmate as quickly as they can
oh this is not three plus two it's three
plus one oh my so the
the
you know it's not yeah the one second
increment difference is huge actually it
means that you can actually flag easier
and i um
i need to watch okay so b6 i believe is
a bad move because of this
um
i think i just
do i take or do i just ignore this i
think i just ignore this let's go h4
you have a queen turn turned on let's
see
uh just just to double check play
pre moves yeah that other queen is on
okay good
very important to have the auto queen on
it can literally save save the game
and lose you the game if it's off and
this time control
uh i kind of want to play g5 but i'm not
sure if i can actually i think i can
that takes stakes
i'm gonna be it's gonna cost me a pawn
if i do it now
actually i would do it anyway why the
heck not okay so my opponent does accept
take take okay no he doesn't think he
could have taken on e4 and taken on g5
but didn't want to do that
i respect it that's fine
let's go here
just to just now just to make sure the
king is is safe
better be safe than sorry as they say
okay so i almost want to play d5 here i
mean maybe i do actually i think i do
want to play d5 heck yeah
and like here
or maybe even rock h e1
because what's gonna happen is that
i believe i'm just gonna have this
crushing idea of net f6
uh the queen is the queen is kind of
stuck if it goes back to d8 uh then i
have i just have a massive attack on the
center so even though i'm down the pawn
here
i uh all my pieces are perfectly
positioned like i don't have to worry
about anything and now
black needs to be worried about the
knight f6 discovery right that's that's
the threat
uh bishop e6 is probably
probably one of the ways probably if not
the only way to to defend against that
of sucks
but let's see
ah thanks for a sage
hoping to learn a few gambits from you
ah that's probably not gonna happen
i'm not a i'm not a gambit guy i
i i play random stuff so i i you know
when i play bullets i usually just play
random openings but i
i do not believe in power in in the
power of gambits i
i play like
normal mainstream openings
um
without really knowing much about them
wait what the bishop e6 wasn't played so
my pawn is going to play this position
down the queen that's i mean i'm all for
it like
yeah i will take the queen thank you
very much
i'm not sure i mean bishop e6 might have
been
i don't know
in my mind it wasn't really that
difficult to see but you know
you know you never know when you play
others okay so i see bishop takes g6 and
it just looks completely lost for black
yeah okay so now i can take on d7 i can
probably even take on f7
i can do whatever i want and i should be
able to win regardless so let's just
take here
i just need to be watching out for for
checkmates in the first rank that's
that's it
if this happens i'll take and and i'm
i'm
a billion percent positive there's going
to be something so kha that's happening
right yeah okay there's no other move i
can so the first first thing i see is
just rook d3 right that's probably the
simplest i can do it now for cafe they
can take
and play queen h5 queen f3 and just just
have a two connected past bones along
with the queen that's uh
there's an explo that's an explosion the
queen and two connected past pawns oh
man that's just that's just over so
let's go for it takes
check take
uh can do queen e3
can do here
if i do queen c c3 than king g6 if i do
queen e3 black will play bishop d6 and
try to stop me from playing f4
which is not a big deal i think i'm just
going to let it happen so bishop b6 is
happening
yeah bishop d6 does happen um
let's go here
now my thread has queen h6 and g6 so
bishop of four is actually a must
very nice now okay queen e7 there is
rook f7 so i cannot do that let's check
here king g8
right kng8 i can also do quench six yeah
so i i'm wait what
this doesn't look right okay so what
about you six check key seven king each
seven i just promote right check here
here that was quick no i wouldn't i
wouldn't call this game quick i mean
quick would be like 20 moves but yeah
this game was like ah
i didn't sacrifice i mean yeah i mean
this this is not really a game but i'm
pretty sure i could have gotten more so
black is not supposed to play b6 in this
position black is supposed to i believe
play c6
and now against h4 they are supposed to
play like early g6 bishop g7 so this
this maneuver that my opponent performed
later later on in the game it's a key
maneuver to stay safe because
essentially my idea is to play h4 hg4 g5
and and black's black needs to black
just needs to hide the bishop over in g7
to stop that
that's how black equalizes here
okay so i guess
i was amongst the ones who finished
first
so now we can focus on looking at other
people's games okay he already won
jeffrey one
i believe there's okay so let's look at
let's look at chris the first game so
christopher is playing black here he is
he is down a pawn
he's also he has also no time so i'm
pretty sure that
unless his opponent blunders like bad
white should why should probably win
this game
even though it's i think
theoretically speaking this is probably
a draw well because we have an opposite
color bishop end game and
oh roxy 5 rook c5 the bose blunder rook
c5
rook c6 roxy what is going on okay i
mean okay there's
i mean there is absolutely no excuse for
blundering this because wise player with
white pieces has 20 seconds here so you
know you don't have to play fast what
white is trying to do here essentially
is trying to flag black but it's not a
good it's not a sound strategy like you
don't have to you can just
win
by
position right
my attack was faster yeah yeah i would
say that matt that you know that that's
that's that's the tricky part about that
line if black doesn't react to it
properly they just lose
that's why i play it especially it's
especially good for blitz but it's not
exactly a gambit
okay kf3 rock d6 yes and now and now
it's going to be even harder for white
to win
yeah see now now some issues
appear right d6 here bucket she's going
to keep moving back and forth and how
does white win okay so king is going to
get to e3 i suppose
and then to
okay but that's how that's it's from
what
it's a three-fold repetition okay well
that's what a rollercoaster i i forgot
how fun how fun blitz uh blitz
tournaments are
because yeah this stuff is gonna it's
gonna keep happening like
all the time
non-stop
oh my kingdom one wow this this is a
very rare
yeah well rook c6 is the only move yep
an extremely rare position where white
has four pawns against the against the
rook and the bishop and and black black
cannot seem to find a way but i'm not
sure if there is a way
uh if if there were no pawns right now
this position would be winning for black
it's winning by force
uh king e1 okay bishop d4
no g no there's g7 no g7 b7
i feel like if if anyone can win here
it's probably why because because of
sheer amount of pawns bishop d4
uh what rookies three rooks is three
rookies three or six oh my god this
one's oh my god what what flag rookie
three just remove the defender from the
g7 square she's rookie three taken c3
and win
uh can i play with you uh chen dan sorry
i'm playing in the tournament right now
so maybe maybe after
playing a woman grandmaster
let's go for queen's gamut accepted here
so play the 4d5 c4 takes
knight d7 is is so my idea is to play c5
but um the reason for why i don't do it
immediately is because there is this
line where white can take on c5 and and
essentially
um transpose into a um
an end game
without queens so i i do not want to
play the end game without queens because
i feel like and blitz is going to be a
pain to to win that position so
uh i would just much rather avoid it
period
so this is a very non-standard position
where i'm not even sure who is better uh
i seem to be doing just fine
but once again i can't really say for
sure who
has an edge right now i i'll kind of
like my position right i have no issues
given that i can finish developing and
that's
and that's what
[Music]
i made i may decide decide to throw this
in
because
uh it it doesn't let white play bishop
before so if white ever played bishop b4
then um
then moving the knight away from c5
would mean the bishop trade but this way
there there's no bishop trade
anymore
i just need to make sure i i don't miss
position my pieces
from this point on let's see let's go
queen b6 i guess
so now i just need to once again because
white already got the rooks out i that's
that's that's my next step
that's what i still need to do the h3
kind of gives me time to do that so
let's let's go for it roxc8 i might be
looking
towards playing something like this
right so that's
uh that's how i'm
intending to make progress
uh usually removing moves like rock c8
is a good idea because well if they if
they happen great you can save a second
or two if they don't happen not a big
deal
i don't really have to take but i will i
mean
um
just you know there was there were some
tricks uh on on the on the d file so
i'm gonna move away
yeah so my opponent seems to be just
trying to trade pieces which i was so
desperately trying to avoid but
um being able to trade doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to survive
clearly my opponent is trying to not
lose this game and
you know when you're playing when you're
playing scared it it sometimes backfires
so let's see what i can do
uh let's play let's start with g6 so
this move is just i'm just making this
move so that my king can run away
if if some stuff on the last rank
happens such as quincy it's not going to
happen right now but in the future it
may it may come in handy like for
example now this allows me to play an a4
not anymore obviously
uh how about i go knight d7 maybe maybe
flip my net over to one of these squares
bishop c4 happens very interesting i'm
not i'm not entirely sure what what the
bishop is doing here
uh okay let's go into e5 so if bishop
goes to b3 that's that's
that's a sign that i i've kind of made
progress okay so my opponent doesn't
fall for it but now i can maybe force a
move such as b3 or f4 or something
something is going to weaken white's
position somewhat
okay this doesn't seem to be doing much
does it
i'm still threatening to take um f4
f4 i can i can just move back to c6 yes
it's gonna lead to uh to to the trade of
knights but
um
if anything once again i'm looking i'm
looking to weaken voice position as much
as i possibly can so you know as as long
as white makes pawn moves i'm happy
here what you see the white yeah white
has to be careful because the fight is
not careful i would have probably
sacrificed on e3 but now with the knight
and c2 look where is the knight going ah
ah hello
knight
i feel like the knight is not going
anywhere anytime soon i'm oh i'm okay i
apologize a1 okay
that can go to a1
uh yeah well
a1 is not exactly
a very good square for the knight to be
on
i'm not sure i'm not sure why i'm
laughing so hard i'm sorry i apologize
but it's just it just looks look at that
beast
i'm sorry
oh
knight a1 yeah um okay well
i shouldn't let my guard down because i
i'm pretty sure i'm winning but i just i
still need to win the game
uh let's go here
trade this way
because because of how how mispositioned
the knight and the queen are or they'll
never be able to work well with each
other and essentially if white takes in
d3
i'm i'm
i'm gonna trade right i'm gonna
take it back with a bishop obviously not
with a queen because our my queen is
defending the bishop on c5
so i'm gonna do that and then my idea is
to play queen e5 and that's why i'm
doing all this so now queen e5 is is
gonna be liso
yeah and that's
game
looks like it right
when a5 i take here and then i take
there
and that's game over
how how position of one single piece can
change the outcome see guys that's yeah
that's just
let's just listen obviously not
following for any any of the yeah any of
the queen d4 stuff right there's queen
d4
oh yeah this was uh
so far it's a smooth sailing
let's see if i can keep keep it up this
is the same way actually it's not very
surprising because like in most of title
2 determines i always begin like really
well like i always go like five to five
six out of six and then and then as a
tournament you know comes to his logical
conclusion i start collapsing
now i i gradually start playing stronger
people and then they beat me and yeah i
kind of
i don't know get demotivated with
something
pony was out of the game oh yeah that
pony was oh
it was not it was not an on a
on a square it would have to be
definitely a one is definitely not it
ah let's let's follow jeffrey's game
here he seems to be oh this is very
interesting
let's see can d4 who is faster it's
going to be a
he's gonna be a
all right excuse me
i'm not sure i'm up i appear to be a
little bit sleepy today
king 5 or black can just stick on h5 no
h6 h6 h wait wait h2 this is no wait h6
this would be interesting but let's fold
it again okay it still happened it still
happened exactly the same way
let's see i'm not sure i'm not sure
what's happening what is going on
i mean black has got to be winning right
g4 end the two pawns two pawns together
are unstoppable just like kf3 key f3 g3
right just anywhere in pawn
or or this yeah this is also fine
and the white flags even though they
could have just resigned
we have
grown master fidel corrales who is a
good friend of mine and also um
my past teammate
unfortunately seems like he is losing
this game because after kg7 black has
queen to g6 which blocks any and all
checks
what is my position well it's only been
two game two rounds so far i won both
games i'll probably maintain my original
position which was a
fourth seed or fifth seed
so the um
you know
the standings begin to matter by around
eight or nine i would say so like when
when the tournament comes to starts
starts coming to a logical conclusion
that's where
that's where your position matters the
most because then like every point
matters and you know
it's basically your your results
directly influence outcome but in the
beginning you know you can have a hiccup
okay for some reason i'm oh wait uh it's
because a whole bunch of never mind i
was not i was not foresee because a
whole bunch of people who were higher it
isn't me joined late
and so i'm like six i'm like tense right
now or something
how many rounds 11 games there are 11
games and there should be a as far as i
remember there should be um
there should be a break
at some point there should be um
five to ten minute break after one of
the games probably after round six
oh okay let's see uh all the games are
over so we are just waiting for the next
games to begin
there we go i am playing
international master from
egypt
very nice so let's go so this time let's
go c4 let's play some english
okay so we it seems like we're gonna
transpose into some kind of king's
indian
setup
let's do it
bishop g4 is a move for sure
this is my line i play this one as black
i'm not even kidding guys this is my
what he takes was a pawn
what the
no take was a knight
why take with the pawn
no
don't no don't play it like this this is
so why why
okay this is this is the this is a
scared approach like you're supposed to
take with the knight there's there's
some really fun lines there that my
opponent probably doesn't know since he
didn't play it i assume he doesn't know
it
but yeah i'm i'm slightly i'm a tiny bit
disappointed that my point didn't play
because i know the refutation
i i knew i know the refutation of that
line that's why i always look so hyped
because because the fight so i have a
funny story to share
basically i played this wine and kings
india i played like very often and i
played in classical games right so the
line is unsound the line is is it's just
straight up bad for black
but even though i have like dozens of
games in this line in in the database
so people can see those games
not a single one of them and i believe
there were at least there were at least
uh
three grandmasters that i played that
line
against
none of them were prepared
i'm not sure how that happened or if
people just didn't prepare for the games
against me but nobody was ever prepared
against that line and i won like every
single game i played in that line like i
played like 11 games there and all of
those 11 games are in the database so
people can see them and people can look
at the line and prepare against it and
nobody did oh i don't know i don't know
what happened because every single one
of them lost to me in that line
but anyway uh let me let me focus uh
focus here on on this game because i i'm
not doing as well as i would like to
i need to
[Music]
whoa
i i need to like what
what am i supposed to do you want to
survive this well there's an f3 this
this looks very very
unpleasant it always happens like this i
always start start talking about
something and then and then get myself
in trouble in the game but it's okay i'm
going to dig myself out of this i have
i have a 20 second advantage on the
clock fortunately knight f3 doesn't win
the game immediately because i take and
then i get to trade queens and i should
be fine
why did you whether they capture with a
g pawn well because of a capture with
the e pawn there is this knight d4 yeah
well it still happened right it should
just it happened eventually it just
didn't happen right away so i would say
that i still kind of
failed
to stop it
so this looks extremely suspicious yeah
like
this looks like i'm just lost um
i
i hope
that i can survive here somehow i'm
obviously i'm looking to play
bishop b2
because that's the kind of development
move i want to make right because my
bishop is clearly not doing anything on
c1 right now
2900 hello felix good to see you
um
takes uh wait do i not just win a pawn
here looks like i'm just winning a pawn
right now no
i mean i can also
oh this he or does he want to play queen
c6 here oh i think that's what he wants
and then i would do oh my god wait i
lost no no wait never mind
no way i am lost did they not lose just
now no i didn't i did not lose oh my god
wait a minute
i'm sorry i i
yeah this
pog champ
folk jump got him
i got him
i got him ladies and gentlemen
oh my god
this has got to be the tilter for my
opponent oh no
um
yeah it'd be like that sometimes what
can you do
it is it is so funny i got so lucky i
got so lucky that this works i mean this
is not well-played at all so let me
explain what happened
okay so what i wondered here is that if
i take on f3 this is actually very cool
if i take an f3 there is this small
queen c6 it depends my queen right
mcqueen is the defender of the rook so
there isn't much i can do other than
just go for a trade and instead of
taking the queen back
black can make this
cheeky intermediate mover takes d1 which
basically wins them the rook
so this is what i blundered and then i
was like oh i'm done for but then i was
thinking to myself oh well what what so
i don't have to take on f3 right because
queen sheet queen g2 is threatening so i
can go wrong g1 right so just just
defend against quinchito and then i was
oh oh wait but then there is rook d1 and
that's exactly what happened so my
opponent just plays this and if you know
under normal circumstances imagine his
my opponent's king is on the h8 right
now
if that's the case i'm lost because i
have to take the rook and then i get
checkmated but just but only because the
king is in g8 i have this amazing just
double double attack and and i win the
rook and instead of losing yeah instead
of losing a win okay well yeah it's uh
yeah it's blitz right
it's gonna keep happening
i'm i'm honestly i'm very happy that i
did not lose this game it's it's yeah
it's
um but yeah i hope i didn't i didn't use
my one time
you know when in a losing position
i will need i will need this to happen
at least
two or three more times during this
tournament
let's see let's follow hikaru's game
his games are always fun to watch oh
this game okay but he's like he's he's
he's a massive time favorite and now c6
and knight b7 looks like it just does it
right c6 knight b7
c6 and b7 car there you go
there you go rock d5 rogue d5 he carl
come on do it rogue takes d5
boom
bishop g3 haha
oh wait he's going for d7 yep yep yep
yep
just like i thought now c7 rook d8
and yeah rook the 87 what is seven
yeah but i cannot stop the promotions
you see someone see this coming
all right hikaru is as clean as ever
let's see oh jeffrey jeffrey's oh my god
jeffrey has yet another end game
well okay but this one is nearly
impossible to win i suppose if anyone
can win is probably black because well
black is gonna is gonna get the h5 pawn
yeah we might have we might have like a
a very very uh long
game here and i you know let's see if
jeffrey survives
because it's not it's not a guarantee
obviously rook d4 king e5 can d2 yeah i
mean
once again practically speaking this is
an easy draw but in blitz you know when
i'm actually surprised to see that that
the title tuesday is is now is now being
played with
excuse me it was three plus one control
instead of three plus two because three
plus one just makes it a bit more
chaotic
oh what okay so yeah it's okay there's
just not a
funny fact uh white can even give up the
bishop in this this this position white
can play king a3 give up the bishop like
in b2k a1 and still going to be a draw
because that's that's a theoretical draw
where white cannot win
uh the promotion square is is is is a is
over wrong color it's supposed to be
i mean black has a wrong bishop the
bishop is supposed to be of the same
color as a promotion square in this case
it's not so it's a draw
uh let's see who else is playing
oh actually a lot of a lot of good
people are playing let's look at
vadimer only shook's
game here he is what ef but why why not
gf okay you see this is this is what i'm
talking about blitz it's blitz for you
although black is still not out of the
boots now e3 is coming oh wait okay
takes
wait but okay that's the first draw why
would you play a five
okay yeah that's just the force draw now
but i mean i probably shouldn't be
should i shouldn't be the one okay okay
this is just not not gonna happen
like there's an increment i understand
if there was no increments so white
could have flagged
but yeah this is just not how it's just
not gonna
happen yeah there you go
okay
like a white is trying to flag they
should just not go into opponent game
to make the defense more difficult
okay we have a draw here
not bad not bad now we have two more
games left
this one
who is playing for the win
i assume black is trying to play for the
win because well i mean actually no
probably white but i mean okay 50 move
rule okay these guys are these guys are
thirsty making 50 50 50 move 50 more
rule draws at this point
nice okay so i have three out of three
this
i'm playing
well who that oh that's anthony buckrow
wow i've played them in classical game
and during french league in 2010 or 2011
not sure which one that's crazy so this
is the first time i play him in like 12
years
let's go exciting
let's play some sloth
oh he takes immediately that's
interesting i've actually never seen
people take right away
that's i would say that's unusual for
this kind of position
i oh i see i see the point so i guess
the point is that now he plays rook c1
right
the queen c is also not very not very
usual honestly
let's see e4 oh it actually makes makes
a lot of sense
what he is doing
but it also makes a lot of sense what
i'm doing
so let's see who makes more more sense
i'm going to play e5 and then if he
takes i'm going to go knight d7 and take
control with the two key squares okay he
goes d5 but but then the problems
persist right the c5 square is still
there
he lo goes for one castle very
interesting okay so knight c5 queen c2
a5 bishop g5 i suppose is going to
happen actually bishop g5 i have knight
takes d5 so he cannot do that very nice
to know
okay wait what about what what if i just
take here
isn't this kind of working oh if he
takes back with e pawn
i guess he can do this yeah okay so
that's what he does yeah
um
what can i do what can i do
i kind of want to play like knight d7 f5
but at the same time i don't i also do
not really want a castle so i however
find it may seem i'm actually going to
play kfc in g8 now because i want to
keep my rook on h as it's already kind
of well placed so if this happens i go
with my e8 and i'm trying to occupy the
d6 square
i feel like i'm i'm in a little bit of
trouble here because once again my my uh
my peace energy is not the best here i
think my opponent is just looking for
some some way to win at this point i'm
not sure if there is one but let's see
you have rook f1 i go kfa so i just need
to make sure my king is my king is
hidden on g8
bishop d6 yes i would like to i would
like to reserve the d6 square for my
knight because the knight is
um one of the best blocking pieces when
it comes to blocking the you know
past pawns
ghost king b1 ago kim ago king g8 that's
fine by me
here i've i probably i'm going to play
samsung b6 now so that um this movie is
so that i can play ad6 later on and take
on c5 retake and see if i'm back with
the pawn
aha interesting so he does this
i mean i see what he's trying to do but
does it work
okay i take
i don't know i'm i mean
this this game is crazy i need i
probably need to be a bit more focused
at this point
my opponent is really strong and i i am
up a pawn but this is not the kind of
pawn i would like to be up
as um yeah as i have a whole bunch of
issues here
for this extra pawn that i've gotten
let's see
what to do what to do what to do
[Music]
hmm
i appreciate some yeah this is a crazy
position i need to be in a full focus
mode
to just not blunder or something
like white can even take on the five and
i have no clue what's going on
um
interesting but
okay
i'm hanging in there
now the question is is there anything
besides
yeah so okay now now
very important where i put my king
should it be h8 or should it be
i think it should be h8
i'm not sure it's just just the feeling
that i have so 97 is the only thing i
see what can do
now i have this knight g6 i have kh
seven
page seven
isn't this just over
queen e6 rook two six i'm up a piece
and forcing a whole bunch of trades it
should be over
queen a7 uh the system i did not see
what about rock b7 now
we look at the [ __ ] is out of the game i
wouldn't say that no i see rocket rocket
h8 was actually the mvp of the game see
it was it was in the right place at the
right time
without the move rock h6 the thing i'm
i'm a toast
so i would i would
disagree with your statements there done
okay well
i'm pretty sure i got a little bit lucky
there as well but you know
the result is what matters and i'm
actually
oh very interesting we have hikaru
versus alexander bortnick match and oh
my god what is going on look at this
queen h2 what is this what is this
madness
rook takes e3
it's like interesting
seven
yeah that's that shouldn't be right q7
king g4 kinji odo yeah quinchi yeah this
is over
or is it g3
ah yeah this is even easier nice
yeah nice
all right so hikaru is crushing it
as usual i think this might be this
might be my time to play him
honestly
well for some reason he's i mean it's
probably because my tie break is higher
for some reason my tie break is the
highest among all the four
four point four pointers there's 14
people with four out of four right now
let's look at
midos game here he won
good timing
he wins as i open up his game
uh who else is there i know that sergey
shigaoko is pretty strong so let's look
at him
real quick
oh
oh it's over oh it's so over
yeah
b1
he wins as well
nice
how about
anton demption oh we have two knights
wow that's that's impressive
well
actually
okay but he took so actually if if black
didn't have a knight there like if black
does not have a knight here i'm pretty
sure it's winning like here if if y just
has two knights and black has it has a
pawn on a5
given that white does not take the pawn
on a5 i'm pretty i'm i'm pretty sure
they win
i'm not i'm not 100 on it but i think
there is a very very difficult way to
win this position with two knights
because essentially
two knights
alone cannot checkmate is a king so if
you have a king and two knights versus
the king it's a theoretical draw but if
you have a king and two knights versus
king and a pawn
depending on where the pawn is
it can be winning
anybody from india playing this room and
i'm pretty sure a lot of indian players
playing are playing right now
okay so there's there's this gentleman
right here
uh
narayanan
and then
maybe a bunch more i'm pretty sure
there's a lot of indian players in this
tournament right now
okay so there's one more game okay this
game where king vs king okay nice
yeah executing that tonight and gaming
bliss would it would indeed be insane so
i i think there's a good chance that the
game was to end in the draw
even if if that did happen i mean even
if
that kind of end game was was reached
but yeah it's really hard to win
we have a next game
in a moment we have 21 people with four
out of four and only
only the best not i wouldn't say only
the best of the best are remaining in
this pool but definitely a very very
tough competition from now on
oh
there is a six there is a planned six
minute break after wait after round four
oh so we are on a break oh never mind's
in
wait oh okay so okay so i see they have
so they moved so now they have two
breaks instead of one
because i believe that okay maybe i i i
think i i understand so
when title use they still used to have
10 rounds instead of 11 is that would
have a break after round five i believe
technically number one yeah let's cancel
the term and you cancel
okay yeah everyone go home
tournament over
because of tie breaks yeah i mean okay
this doesn't mean anything i just i just
happened to play
um yeah i just happened to play
people who are now
doing better right that's how tie breaks
are calculated you just you know you
just take your opponent's performance
your opponent's points and you add to
your tie break and that's that's why my
opponent is just just my previous
opponents just happened to
to be doing well after they lost to me
but yeah um we actually have
we actually have a small break
uh yeah actually yeah let me tell you
guys a little story so you know like in
in in ukraine and russia there are
dedicated schools for chess and i was
very lucky to to be accepted into one of
them and it was actually free of charge
you didn't have to pay anything to go
and
um i know that uh situation in here in
america is different
so um
you know while
um your you know if any of you would
like to contribute um to by donating or
subscribing to this channel i just
wanted to remind you that you know 100
of the switch subs bits and all the ad
revenue generated by bias influence
chess club twitch channel uh will uh go
to support scholastic initiatives in
this influence area and your guys
support directly helps children receive
formal chess instruction in their school
to make a direct donation you can use
the command explanation mark donate
and donations of 75 or more will pay for
an entire semester of chess programming
for one child and we thank you very much
for your generous support
yeah and you know i i do know that it's
it's tough uh you know not not not
everybody can afford uh chess education
in in the united states and uh it's it's
really nice uh of centralist chess club
to to be contributing towards towards uh
um
this cause because um i believe the
chess education should be available to
everyone
and yeah break duration i believe the
break is about to end
actually very soon
let me see it's 12 places so probably
another two to three minutes i would say
the the breaks are
six minutes long
so this one has been going on for some
time and then there is going to be one
more after round eight
so let's hope that i can
i can uh
i can stay strong until round eight
once again early on if if if you so yeah
so out of 11 i would say that probably
nine and a half would be clear first
nine would be
would have a good shot of of getting
into
into some prizes
so yeah uh
a single loss is not gonna like be
critical but but if you lose two games
then then it's basically
uh i wouldn't say it's over
uh uh in terms of uh trying to go for
for prizes but it's definitely gonna be
very difficult
because there will no longer be any
margin for error
so yeah let's see let's see how i do
oh yeah
my my fourth game was against a very
very strong opponent and yeah i've done
pretty well so let's let's hope i can
keep up with it
i do want to play hikaru
it's gonna be my personal goal my
personal goal is okay so we have like
about a minute
did i prepare for hikar i did not
prepare for anybody uh this is this is
this is me just
just waking up today and deciding to
play that on tuesday even though i
haven't played in one for like half a
year at least
what's hikara's weakness i don't see he
has weaknesses i think he is a perfect
human being he is maybe his weakness his
current weakness is that he is not 100
in terms of health because he was very
unfortunate to get covered during his
uh during his trip to
um to poland while he was playing in
world rapid and bullets he unfortunately
got covered and i'm not sure if he is if
he is out of it now or if he is still
kind of struggling but i wish him all
the best and i hope that he he can he
can he can fight this this disease off
i believe hikaru is also streaming right
now right yeah he is
i'm i i i do have to command him for for
like just staying strong and even even
while he he wasn't feeling his best he
just kept the streams going and
um yeah
so he has a very strong personality okay
so i'm playing yet another grand master
from cuba this time
let's see how this goes
um let's play
i
kind of want to play the same line
because well it's been working kind of
i'm going to play e3 now
this is a tricky line that not many
people know how to deal with so let's
let me try it uh a45 is a good is a good
reaction yeah
he carries to me a hikaru yeah hikaru
streams very often
now neither fail i believe is a move and
now um i have h3
h3 is just just meant okay h6 um i mean
i should do the same good sir
so h6 is against bishop g5 h3 is against
bishop g4 so oh and ib8 very interesting
when you were so the knight is coming to
c6 and then to b4 i assume
okay
i understand
half of the half of the job is to
understand your opponent's plan
so usually the bishop would go to a3 if
not allowed to go to f4 or g5 but this
time i'm gonna actually switch switch it
up a little bit and
and do this this
you know
this little battery
okay so my opponent is
playing quite well let me let me see
what i can do let's go rookie 2 double
on the e file so if i was
is going to be um
the place of well where most of the
action is going to be happening so
that's what i'm going to be doing i'm
going to be preparing
preparing stuff on that file
like before okay now if r1 i have to be
um very careful about the bishop f5 and
that's probably what my opponent is
trying to tell me that oh well there is
bishop of five
what in the world are you doing
i'm not gonna say
that's a nonsense i'm gonna just
politely agree and maybe play something
like this actually this would this would
lead to me sacrificing exchange i
i'm not sure if i'm ready to sacrifice
an exchange to be honest uh let's just
go here this looks a bit crazy because
it weakens my
my king's position
a little bit but it stops bishop five
so that's all i need to do just stop
bishop of fire play rookie one and
follow up with some bishop f4 i want to
get
control over the e file
let's see
looks weird
but if it works it works you know
my opponent is struggling because
however
my opponent's position may seem okay but
but uh they they do miss some space yeah
so i have a space advantage space
advantage right now
actually g5 was also an interesting
possibility
and i should be watching out for some g5
ideas even here like g5
it doesn't seem to be doing much at all
huh
okay how about name b no knight b5
no knight b5 is
not great i believe how about i do this
actually i don't know bishop of fire is
any yeah the bishop of fire was a threat
because it would come to d3 that's why
that's why i felt uh felt the urge to
stop it also g5 here
actually would win me upon actually
let's let's do it so this wins me a pawn
because i take on b7 and go back uh yeah
it does compromise my king's position
quite quite a bit
but that's that's the kind of risk i'm
willing to take for
for the extra material
let's go back now i'm just i'm just at
this point right i'm up material at this
point all i need to do is just trade
trade trade rate
just remove any and those threats okay
knight h5 is a
there's a nice move stopping me from
playing bishop before because bishop of
four is
like my main idea that's that's a way
for me to trade as many pieces as i
possibly can
uh how about i do this
yeah let's do it
i am blundering at a four which is a a
very big deal
you're watching hikara also
wish him wish him good luck for me
here
there there uh
[Music]
that just
kind of
kind of bad
that's kind of bad
not gonna lie how about
yuck
ah
all right let me see i gotta go focus
at this point i have to focus because if
i don't i lose
let's do this
ah let's do this
i also need to start removing because
i'm down like 10 seconds on my clock
my opponent is taking a lot of time
which is great news i have i need all
the time i can get
what
this works this is madness if it works
it does what the heck
what the heck
what is this
so stupid
this is so stupid like how did i not win
this game
this is so dumb
this is just so winning man it's that's
i'm so pissed
i'm gonna try to win this is obviously a
force draw like no no no questions asked
about it
okay let's not let's not waste any time
yeah this is
this is horrible like the fact that i
did not win this position is absolutely
horrendous
um
i'm pretty sure there's a lot of ways to
win
once again there's blitz and anything
can happen but i think the simplest is
probably to just you know at some point
yeah this happened
and like i i thought i can just keep
pushing but but essentially what
happened was
the white pieces got in the perfect sync
with each other so i have to play kiki
six now this was probably the moment
where i just i just threw the game away
because here
i cannot play rook d8 i thought i can
play rook gear but i can't because of
bishop g5 and i'm losing the rook and
actually lose the game so my only i
think this is still winning if i play
king six
all i have to do is just keep pushing
the pawns right so i just need to make
sure i have i also had a lot of time but
i made the same mistake
as some people do i was trying to flag
my opponent because my opponent was
playing in increments with like no time
on the clock at all so i thought i can
just win by either winning or just
flagging them
actually to slow down
and and thought about this because this
position clearly has become a little bit
tricky and i i had to like here like
this looks like i may even lose okay if
my opponent just keeps pushing the spawn
i feel like i might even be lost at this
point it's just that they they went for
for an easy way out which is a draw
but definitely
you know their their white pieces are
working perfect with each other and
they're just holding everything so that
now black can focus on promoting their
own pawn it's probably still a draw but
i'm probably the one making it at this
point
okay
all right so
uh nothing
nothing happens
nothing critical happened here black is
gonna oh why is gonna win
you just gotta make sure y doesn't stale
mate somehow f7 kh7
yeah
this game is over
what about the other game
oh
there's a game black also won
rook f7 a very unfortunate
i mean white's position was lost anyway
oh
playing one of the indian players let's
go
also has four and a half
now let's play d6 explain something
something funny i don't know what i'm
doing but
this looks interesting
what is this like my phone is supposed
to be an e5 at this point my phone is
probably like what the heck what the
what the heck in the world is happening
like this is so bad but it's okay
i like playing bad positions from time
to time
uh let's do this
take
yeah
and now just d6 is gonna happen right
at some point maybe not immediately but
eventually
yeah
all right let's do this and then play c5
very next move okay
okay this is not as bad actually this
might not be it might not even be as bad
as i thought it's going to be
now if d takes c6 i go knight c6 and i
get monet over to d4 it's yeah it's it's
a game
obviously let's not gonna so let's not
talk about how i how i got to this
position but it's
it could have been much worse let's put
it this way
okay so
what is that that i need to do here okay
i don't know i don't really have any
experience playing positions like this
not gonna lie so let's play a6 for now i
kind of just take control over the b5
square it may be a weakness
might be creating some weaknesses for
myself but that's okay
in bishop c4 finally enough i'm just
going to rock a fade back and just just
make sure the pawn is
safe and sound okay so now b4 is is kind
of annoying
uh maybe that's why i need to play like
something like queen c8 here
all right let's try it and this is
this this is so this is so stupid
this is yeah this is like very dumb
oh b4k c4 he has d6 right that's
very very very very unfortunate or is it
very unfortunate how unfortunate is on a
scale from one to ten how do you how how
does how unfortunate do you guys think
this is
i wouldn't say it's
that bad
d6 i lose a pawn right bishop c4 it
happens but have made defense and in the
end i have queen b8 and then and then
the opponent d6 just falls and maybe i
can survive there like who knows
let's see
but what i do know for sure is that if
my opponent doesn't win this game
they're going to be totally
crazily tilted
okay d6 happens i go
i go
i go
yeah i saw this
but i thought it's going to be okay
because i have this move
and now b5 i'm just going to let it
happen so it takes
right b5 here and then i have b5
ah he does this interesting okay that's
that's fair i did not see this
i would say i didn't see this at all but
this is probably even better
than taking an mp5
let's see queen d8
yeah the rook is annoying the the rook
is definitely a problem right now
all right let's let's do this right
[Music]
here and then bishop e6 is that what i'm
gonna do
i guess right here roxy one
bishop now bishop e6
yeah bishop e6 now or
or later i think now
yeah let's do it now
because if he takes yet i can take with
this one
he can go f3 but then i have some f5 and
the game becomes crazy that's exactly
what i need actually i need the game to
become as crazy as possible so i can
have a winning chance
i don't mind this
this this is looking
interesting to say the least
uh what am i blundering something
um
did it blunder i mean i had
there's no way right i had to blunder
what what did that blunder takes
what am i blundering what am i
blundering
check i don't see i don't understand
let's see
maybe he just wants to play rook d7 and
do i need the bishop yeah i don't need
the bishop what am i even asking
of course i need the bishop who doesn't
need the bishop
but yeah oh i see he has rock d7 that's
that's probably what what's what's up
okay so let's yeah let's let's go for it
i see i see what's what my opponent okay
no he's just taking
interesting
okay so i take
oh wait i can't take what am i doing i
can take here
yeah let's take here
rook d7 probably has to be played i
think
yeah rook d7 was indeed played
oh no my time
oh shoot
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i was probably winning i was i i
guarantee you i was winning when i was
up at peace but this is just this is
just a ridiculous way of of ending the
game look at this draw i mean my games
are ridiculous in this tournament all
right uh i mean there's gotta be
like
okay the reason for why i was so
confused because now queen f7 rook g8
and this is a very tricky position yeah
because i can't move any of my pieces
but i think i think yeah so instead of
this my opponent played h4 here and i
was i was just kind of not sure what to
do and also i was running out of time
pretty sure it just
kind of confused myself a little bit so
i think i put some sort of d3 and yeah
there is compensation for white because
white does have two pawns for the for
the bishop and also they have this this
these annoying like ideas that are there
all the time so
never mind i mean
it's it's a good result we had a very
exciting game you know and
i you know
i that's what i wanted unfortunately for
for me i i was about to saw here you see
i spent 46 seconds
just to take the bishop
obviously i wasn't expecting the i
wasn't expecting my opponent to take i
was expecting this to happen or or just
like rook d7
and then something like this um which
would be
really bad but i i remember i yeah so
okay never mind
done
done we gotta focus on the next game we
have two more games until
you have no zero zero one seconds left
tens draw yeah yeah
well
that's that's how it's going to be from
now on because i'm playing a grandmaster
every game like grandmaster every game
it's it's really tough
especially because uh a lot of these
people they have like way more
experience playing bullets than myself
like i've only recently came back to
to playing blitz online
and uh
yeah i'm still rushed i mean like okay
like
i've been saying this like so so much
them rusty and stuff but you know that's
just the truth
um
a6 yeah okay let's go a3 there's going
to be e5
yeah takes takes takes stakes
castles
right
uh let's just play this on like i know
this position is probably not great for
white but
why not
yeah
let's take play g4 now
oh shoot that's
yeah that's
that came really quickly and i just
didn't realize that
i cannot take because of bishop b2
that's
yeah that's uh that is a problem
that is the problem indeed let's go here
yeah my position is pretty bad at this
point like i've
i've given up the initiative
it pains me to say it but i may have to
look for ways to survive because there's
some i'm pretty sure my opponent is
looking for some tactics at this point
there's also queen a2
that doesn't seem to be doing much
because i always have bishop c3
[Music]
yeah so here we just goes from d6 what
if i go here
my opponent is spending some time but
same can be said about me
i've spent some time and yeah now you're
even
my position is not great but maybe just
maybe i can survive this let's see
oh heck why do i why am i saying it as
if i cannot win maybe i can survive and
win at the same time
play you more we always draw
i promise i'll break the curse of us
always drawing
felix
i'll be the one to break the curse i'll
be the one to beat you
what is this f5 i'm honestly
honestly quite surprised about this move
let's go let's take let's play bishop c1
just
does is that
okay
um i cannot take because then
no i can i don't mean i cannot take i
can take and play here no isn't this
just
really good
there is none g3
i guess that's gonna trade whole bunch
but i have i have an end game where i
have
a whole bunch of central pawns i i
prefer my position to my opponents there
at any time of the day
and i'm pretty sure yeah that's that's
the only same opponent can do actually
do i want to take on g3 or do i want to
take an f5 first that's a question i
think i just want to
do i want to take it all
man i i'm i'm starting to double double
double gas myself i shouldn't be doing
saturn bullets like yeah this is like so
much time spent at this point
why
but i'm definitely i'm the one who is
trying to win or so i think
yeah there's rook h6 but i have like
rook f3
actually oh wait no
what am i saying i don't have rook f3
i'm stupid
i am stupid i'm stupid though
help
help
i need somebody's help not just
anybody's help
you know i need someone's help
i'm playing downs upon
[Music]
down upon
but
but we make it exciting we make it down
a pawn but exciting down upon
because bishop e5 go bishop if i dare
you do it
do it
come on
come on do it you won't
how to bait your opponent into
blundering do it you want
my opponent realizes something is
seriously wrong here
yeah it's not going to be simple huh
you're not going to get piece of ilya so
easily
um
yeah sure bishop c3 what now
what now
look at this look at this pawn it's just
the pawn be running the pawn be running
us crazy
okay that's fair so let's
let's do it i suppose although there is
this this aha
i see i see what my opponent is trying
to do here
they're trying to be very tricky and
that's fair because that's the only way
they're gonna accept draw are you crazy
no
what do you mean except the draw hell no
you're playing this on this is exciting
why draw
let's go here
don't look for easy ways out
it's just not gonna happen
i'm pretty sure i'm lost here
or am i i mean i got to do i got the
queen with a checker get the queen with
a check
but that's i'm not sure if that's how
that's going to help me
i mean i queen was a check right yeah
i mean this is crazy like we have we
literally have
we literally have a position where my
king is in d3 and my opponent's king is
god knows where as well
he's just one of waking c4
oh god save me
i just wanna i mean i just can't help it
i just i'm just gonna do it quincy four
and here i'm just gonna do like this
yeah
this is what the heck is going on the
rook is hanging
okay
uh
is
seven wait i can't wait what i can't can
i
let's go here
like i don't care who wins at this point
i just don't care okay takes
here
hello
hello darkness your old friend
you've come to talk to him again
ship it to papa let's go
what in the world has happened
what is this what is this
look at that
what's this what is this wha what is his
position as a knt for
oh my god
i mean
i'm kind of proud of myself i'm really
enjoying myself
and and my way of playing this term and
i'm gonna lie
so we're gonna have a break after the
next game
let's hope i can i can
finish the next game strong honestly the
reason for why i always do so well in
the beginning and then like kind of fall
behind by the end is because i get
extremely tired and that's actually i
i'm feeling it i feel it happen
my my stamina is below the lowest point
imaginable like i i'm a very
i'm a very weak person physically oh
hello hello danish
why not bishop default check well bishop
d4 check where
yeah i was i was calculating it so here
for example
bishop before just c5
i didn't know what to do after c5 i
didn't want to take on c5 because
i can't check anymore i i don't want to
ch and also the queen b1 is threatening
right queen b1 is and probably some
checkmate is gonna be there so i just
wanted to play it safe you know just
play keynesian playing bishop c3 if my
opponent lets me i can even just i can
just go all the way back to a2 and
because i have a passer on e6
i'm expecting myself to be winning but
then my opponent found this very tricky
move point c2 and now i was trying to
avoid the perpetual check because
if it would be a perpetual check at
least if i if i didn't do something
about quinine force the hands i put b3
now my opponent should have probably
just played k7 here although yes this
this is just craziness my camera usually
keep it's just gonna keep rolling maybe
even king d5 actually kd5 seems a bit
more precise because this leaves me with
a chair with an opportunity to give a
check from d4 if i need it and then the
king can just keep going
yeah
so this is just crazy and here yeah once
again so i know that if i if i get to
trade queens i just i'm just winning
because the pawn promotes yeah that's
what happened
um i'm not sure if my opponent could
have done anything different because if
they don't do this i i just go
maybe i should just i should have just
gone here right e7 e8 maybe i should
just like
not care
also here rook f2 was a possibility i
just noticed
which might have been a little bit of a
problem for me
because rock f2004 is coming so maybe
yeah maybe i maybe i did blunder after
all
well i won
what to say
i'm definitely not playing perfect
but it's it's all right
and black is going to win this one
because the bishop is of the right
square
oh my god hello
hello i'm playing midway
he kind of destroyed me in a bunch of
our game we played a small match about a
week ago
um
i'm telling him that it's a rematch time
because he beat me back here i think he
beat me like three and a half half
about about a week ago
so maybe i can take this this game as a
chance to
to um
you know
cancel the adoption
he kind of
all right so he's saying that it's it's
really late where he is right now so
it's gonna be tougher for him to play
but yeah
you know let's let's hope that we'll
have a very nice game here
okay so he's playing like really
conservative lines
just kind of getting the pieces out now
might be threatening e4 at some point so
i i've okay bishop of four is
i don't know i'm not a big fan of bishop
before once again it's it's a move that
that um kind of wastes time
uh i'm about to make a move that i'm not
going to be a big fan of myself just to
move f5
just to over protect the knight on e4
and then i'll play e6
next
so we'll have a like a fun exchange um
of of of pieces here if it goes in e5 we
can just like trade a bunch and
and and yeah just like this yes exactly
we can trade a bunch i'll probably play
something like queen c7 then he is going
to go f4 i'm going to go e6 and
this looks extremely drawish not gonna
lie he can try with some g4s
uh that's definitely a valid plan so
let's see what he does so g4 is
is okay i i have b5 so i have a counter
player of my own and if he if he fails
the the play on the on the king's side
then
yeah so uh let's let's respect it and
let's play queen e7 just just taking
away the h4 square from his queens he
goes a5
that is an interesting decision
i'm always i always i'll almost feel
like taking and then just playing c4 i
know that it may seem a bit strange but
at this way i'm cementing i'm kind of
like making sure the b to pawn is not
moving anywhere so that's that's that's
going to be my game plan my game plan is
going to be doubling up on the b file
and just putting as much pressure
against the b2 pawns as i possibly can
let's see if it works
actually now rook b6 there is e4 what i
just noticed so let's play rook b5 first
and now it's still the same issue if i
go rogue b6 yeah if i go a5 he has some
b4
no actually no it does he doesn't so
let's go a5 now
next i'm playing rook b8
yeah so rook b8 is happening
and bishop f3 so he's trying to play h4
and he's claiming that my attack is a
nuisance
that's not nice my attack isn't nuisance
it's a sound idea
good sir
yeah so
wait so what oh here's rook g2 okay got
it
okay he takes should they take back with
e or should they not take back this e
i think i should just take back with g
honestly and then he goes through g5 yes
this is getting a little bit annoying i
would say um
i'm up on time though that that makes me
feel better about myself even though the
position may not follow but
time is a very big factor
in in this tournament so let's see uh
now let's let's flip our bishop over to
g6
actually he can do the same as his he
can play like bishop d1 and
make it a little bit tough
for me to
get my bishop over to g6 okay here goes
h4 i guess the idea is that if i go
bishop g6 he goes to h5
okay
but now as he's gone h4 i can i i may
see this as a green light to try and
play a3 or something
also do i really want to do that
i don't know yeah chess is a hard game
sometimes because you're really you're
you don't know what's good and what
isn't
um
[Music]
yeah let's do bishop of seven and now if
h5 i'm gonna go h6
yeah h6
yeah this is a very tricky position here
okay five but nothing is really
threatening queen g straight always have
rook g8 here
so um not much i need to be afraid of um
on that side
at the same time if he moves the bishop
too far away the pawn on h5 becomes
kind of an easy yes so let's do this
rook g8 queen e1
okay
i see now
and that is
a tiny bit annoying but let's go back
here uh now if he takes i can take back
with the rook because once again his h5
pawn is
his h5 pawn is under attack so this is
gonna be even trade if he takes an a4 i
take an h5 and actually don't mind that
even trade at all because
he goes for another even trade wait but
but now if you do even trade you can't
beat me anymore you understand that
right
so with this even trade
i think the position just becomes kind
of equal
so i need to i need to make a choice do
i want to go for this kind of even trade
or do i want to keep pressure on i think
i'm just going to do even trade play
bishop e8 and try to win this so my plan
for this position is going to be get
making over to f8
i'll operate for why i'm doing this a
bit later
yeah so i'll go king g7 he's gonna just
just do nothing i suppose yeah see so
i'll go king of f8
queen g2 now i'm gonna go queen b7 so
this is gonna force his queen to stay on
the second ring
um let's go over here
okay if i go here he has
queen h4 so let's play bishop no ah
i don't know yeah let's go queen b6
let's let's yeah let's let queen h4
happen he doesn't bite
uh let's play queen c5 try to play a3
let's play e3
okay uh goku is seven so now now i'm
going to bring the king all all the way
over there
and try to make something happen so
let's go queen a5 for now
kc7
uh let's go bishop c6
uh yeah it's gonna be tough to break
through this unfortunately here
some queen c5 maybe
uh gets the ah here yeah how can i win
this like ever like i don't i don't see
i don't see what is what is that i can
do to break through this okay here
check maybe that's what i'm supposed to
do
take
uh take
check wait
check
check
uh check
uh let's do check
check
because if i take the pawn at any given
time he's gonna he's gonna have
perpetual like probably 100 guaranteed
so let's do a couple more checks
and play something like d4 here
oh wait he could have taken oops
oh i think it's just a draw still
yeah it's just a draw ah yeah
hi yeah
i thought
i got you
ggs
was there a perpetual rook b2 at what
point uh arcadipto
i thought i thought this was it i said
this was my moment to shine but
unfortunately
um
yeah here yeah if i take yeah if i take
on f4 he has like he's gonna keep
checking on the sixth rank
so i guess this is probably just still a
draw unfortunately well i mean i'm i
haven't lost a single game i'm
i have six and a half out of eight i've
lost one one and a half points i still
i'm i'm still in
uh in a good standing
for
for top three i just need to well i mean
obviously once again the knight and nine
and a half probably is gonna do it
for
for clear first but he car is obviously
crushing it with seven and a half out of
eight right now
so i have three more games three more
very tough games awaiting me
both rooks and queens and you're
claiming
with both rooks and queens you're you're
you're saying there was a perpetual
after rugby two
um
ah wait at what point right there there
is no
i i uh at no point could it could i have
taken on b2
i think yeah here
oh you mean here oh
you're right i didn't i didn't even
consider you're correct yeah i can take
yeah you see very nice
very nicely spotted but
once again since i was trying to win i
wasn't even looking at this yeah
yeah
nice
so i was just kind of kind of trying to
to make stuff happen and i did but
unfortunately that wasn't enough the
position is just so so solid for both
both sides that yeah it's really hard to
win for either one of us
oh well um minue is a very strong player
obviously do not mind the result at all
we have one more game going on oh it's
uh it's an infamous rook and four versus
rook and three but
the uh sideways four pawns has double
pawns on the f5 oh my god rick d1 go for
it rogue d1 no what go you gotta go run
d1 king one d1 yes go rogue d1
but
but why but why not run d1
does he does he just not want to go into
the pawn end game but i don't think what
can go into opponent game this is this
is lost right
this is just lost
boom right this opponent gives loss of
white cannot go into it and if it
doesn't let's see if i plays rochester
k7 maybe that's what he was afraid of
there's king of one now the checkmate
and one is threatening so this is this
is a must okay white could have also
done this and kind of pushed the
blocking all the way over to h1 but i
mean this is this is a great chance
what has to do is if they're if they're
trying to win which i suppose
they were
all right anyway
we have a six minute break
oh
yeah i'm feeling the fatigue is catching
up onto me
have i ever played title tuesday before
oh yeah probably about five to six times
but i've had i've i've never i've never
really done well i've i would always
start very well but
but then something would happen and i
would lose a whole bunch of games in a
row which may still happen i'm going to
knock on the wood and try to not jinx
myself but
yeah i would just usually just kind of
collapse
collapse by the underdetermined and also
twice like out of those six times that i
played title tuesday i had a bad
experience where i was playing somebody
who
was using using help of the program
like basically who was cheating and uh
yeah somehow
i managed to beat them once and then
obviously the second game i lost but
yeah that's it's just
you know not not only was i not
doing well like in my overall score but
it was also you know having experience
of playing against cheaters and
it uh it didn't help it
further discouraged me from from
participating in that title to use the
events but i figured that this is
probably one of the one of the best ways
of practicing because you know you're
playing like all the title players and
like the strongest players in the world
play in this event so i use this as an
opportunity to practice
my my my blitz as opposed to winning
prizes so yeah
who is figaro going to be playing he's a
he's a sole leader with seven and a half
out of eight
then there is there are quite a few
people with seven points and then
we have a whole bunch of people with six
and a half including myself that's that
makes it what 12 people i believe so i
do have
um yeah i do have
quite a few strong opponents to still
play against uh
see
would be would be very interesting to
play against uh anger master badur
jabala he's a very exciting player to
play against and just in general a very
nice guy so yeah
looking forward to it i'm probably going
to face him if both of us do well or
maybe both of us don't do well
in the next round
wow hicarus look at this look at
hikaru's tie breaks
he's he's even if he even if he shares
the first place at this point
his tie break is 44.75 which is seven
seven points ahead of the next contender
which is jeffrey and myself actually
so even if he even if he somehow
managed to share
first or second place to see car he's
just gonna outdo us on tie breaks
anyway we have we have about a minute
and a half until the end of the break so
yeah
i'm i'm really hoping like nope i like
no pressure but um maybe maybe this is
the one
it would be cool if i could you know
have a good result entitled tuesday for
once
okay let's see
he carries hikaru's rating is 3200 oh my
god
oh i'm actually nearing 3 000 myself so
maybe okay but 3200 is unreasonable
i would have to like
have
a perfect score against people of my
level which is very hard to do
all right let's go come on
started i can't wait
all right games are about resume
playing alexandre moscovenko
sure
very strong remaster from russia
let's do it
let's play some of this
uh okay
just play this position normally i guess
i'm not sure exactly what my queen is
doing on c2 but
oh well
you know you can't you can't
get perfect setup all the time sometimes
it has to be like this
also this might have transposed into
something i'm going away so let's play
c5 now i'm i'm sure c5 is
um i mean it gives up the control over
the d5 score which is a little bit
annoying but at the same time i do get
ready to get
some write some connection between my
pawns and the c5 pawn is
is is taking away quite a few important
squares from black
before
okay that's fair i for some reason i
kind of um
missed um well
not quite missed but i kind of didn't um
think too long about the the possibility
of black plane b4 and here actually i
have i have a5 myself so this this way
i'm cementing the b4 pawn and also i'm
actually looking to play knight b6 at
some point and get rid of the varanoi
net in g5 so let's see how this is once
again this is
a very non-standard position that's
that's what i'm looking for
whenever i play
anybody i'm looking for non-standard
positions for you know it's unclear what
to do and you know those are i believe
those are the positions where i where i
perform the best
um
no particular reason it's just it's just
my observation
okay so here let's play bishop f1 just
just to prevent network 4 in the future
and get ready to planet e5
also knight d6 is going to be coming so
my opponent needs to be very of that now
knight b6 has become a possibility this
looks very very unpleasant for black at
this point let's see
okay takes takes takes
a5 i assume your a5 did happen now what
if what if i go on e5
knight e5
this looks like really bad for black i
don't know i'm i could be just horribly
wrong about my evaluation but this looks
i mean in classical game i think i would
win this position 100 times out of 100
that i would play it
but obviously in blitz anything can
happen and i should not let my guard
down i i will be i'll be looking to
trade queens at this point
trading queens will help me um help me a
bunch because then the knight count can
never leave c6 if never leave c6 the a5
pawn will fall and and i have basically
i have the full control with the d file
at this point
um
bishop d3 just wins
am i crazy
or my opponent is deliberately trying to
give give me uh
oh i see okay
i think i understand
i can color d7 now though right let's go
i'll work this on queen c2 okay so this
there's queen d5 and then
oh no i don't get it let's go
takes oh okay so yeah that's what i
thought
but
i mean
that's a queen is a queen right
yeah
the queen is a queen and i if i don't
win this position while being up a queen
i'll be kind of i kind of stop i was
kind of gonna stop respecting myself a
little bit
so let's not that's not why this
happened
i shall not lose self-respect for myself
at least not yet
i'm not yet at that stage of my life
or hopefully i'm not
uh okay so takes queen d7
uh-huh it looks a little bit sauce right
so let's just take here
i i do need to be variable of this pawns
but because i took on d4 now i'm going
to be threatening checkmates of my own
and i chase so next move is bishop of
six if black doesn't react and
looks like black is a little bit a
little bit too slow with their contra
attack
on the queen's side
yes bishop of six and quinnish fork when
there
should conclude the game
um
i mean fourth checkmate right here
takes when i shake pinches seven
all right so this one this one is good
this one was very very smooth uh
easier than i expected not gonna lie i
just immediately got yeah this is like
b5 is is a very typical idea but i think
my opponent just didn't realize here my
opponent probably should have played a5
like to be fair because letting me play
five uh basically semantics pawn on
before because it makes it a weakness
and it lets me play a b6 and just just
those reasons alone are probably enough
to claim that i have that my position is
better and the
the controller the d5 score is not
enough to compensate for all the
weaknesses that black
uh received was with their play so yeah
this was this was really
smooth like maybe i mean obviously i'm
not the only one who is fatigued at this
point i should also remember that my
opponents are also you know kind of
following the following falling back
uh in terms of their strengths because
let's say underdetermined everyone is
going to be playing slightly weaker
now this might be my chance
oh i can use this time to
to take a little break and hikaru is
actually going to lose this game which
is very very very it's it's it's crazy
he is definitely lost can you have two
king g3
kg4
oh
yeah
he lost that's that's unusual for hikaru
to lose i guess some blunder happened
somewhere along the way yeah okay so
first of all here this this happened
very unfortunate right so here just
bishop a3
was a threat and i'm not sure maybe
maybe it was a deliberate
exchange sacrifice although i
don't think that's the case i'm very
surprised hikara didn't make this move
though this move looks very nice for
black because it's a double attack
attacks both d4 and f2
so i guess you see yeah everyone is
fatigued at this point so i should yeah
i shouldn't obviously i shouldn't let my
guard down but yeah i'm
i'm
you know
i'm in there
so now eight points out of an out of
nine will be uh
will be shared first let's see there's
there's there's two more people who can
get to eight eight out of nine and then
they'll i assume they're going to be
playing each other and there's a high
chance of actually get to play hikaru
next game
as black unfortunately but once again
and blitz
color
usually doesn't matter much okay now
there's three people with zero nine
hecarim is weak well yeah i mean he's
probably i would assume that he's he's
still he might still be a little bit
sick
um
obviously doesn't mean that uh he's
still hikaru you know
still really strong okay so i feel like
hikaru is going to go it's going to
hikara is going to play up because
there's only three people with eight out
of nine so some one of them will have to
play down and hikaru is definitely the
one who is gonna who's gonna play them
um
not a bad opportunity not gonna lie so
there we may see a case where
if hikaru wins
and then the other two guys
that have eight out of nine they'll play
each other for sure if those two guys
make a draw we may see
a huge tie for first with eight eight
and a half out of ten
we have four more games going okay we
have we're gonna this game is going to
last for a long time because it's a rook
and a bishop versus rook essentially
given that white can win
some pawns here
not entirely sure how because the
black rook all black needs to do yeah
okay
yeah they decide to save uh to save some
some strength and just not torture
themselves here because all black has to
do is just keep the rook over on the
sixth rank
okay i'm playing yeah i'm playing a very
strong remaster from israel
let's go
some carol
b4 interesting i do not know before
this is like a big novelty for me like i
have no idea what's what's happening now
but let's just play fast and hope that
i'm right
hmm
not sure if i'm too happy to let this
happen but i guess i have to right oh he
takes with a queen very interesting okay
that's what he's going to take with a
pawn
but no it's fine
once again it's a very non-standard
position very exciting my planet cannot
castle because of my queen on e6 so
that's kind of good
uh let's go here if i ever play c5 he's
gonna get to play b5 and that's why i'm
not sure if i want to do that quite yet
but at the same time what is my opponent
what can my opponent do
it's a it's a funny it's a funny like
took swung up position where my opponent
doesn't really want to play e5 because
it compromises like the light squares
even more
um b5 is is a is a possibility but it's
it's it white has to sacrifice and white
has to be ready to sacrifice the
material there
uh otherwise i don't really see um a
sound plan for white here
i don't really see a sound plan for
myself
well that's that's a different question
like i'm not sure if i
what should i oh wait no it's still it's
the white smooth okay so let's see
my opponent is taking his sweet time
when f3 happens so i guess he's he is
planning on playing
uh there
let's play bishop e7 just getting ready
for the end game
this may bait him to go back right to go
back to e3 and and try to flip his queen
over to g5 okay no it does not okay so
so we just have like some kind of like
an equal position i believe here
right yeah okay so okay b5 happened but
this gives me this gives me the c file
right so i'm i'm surprised to see if my
opponent just gives me a c file like
this i mean i guess he's i guess he's
hoping to play a5 now right like a5 he
takes takes a5
yeah okay so let me just go back and ask
what's going on
what is happening
i can take and plan a b6 and then b3 is
going to happen
yeah this
looks a okay i guess
let's do it
i don't really see how i'm losing so why
not let's do it knight b3 knight c4 i'm
gonna get to playing with b7 next
okay so knight c4 now is kind of
impossible so let's program b7 instead
now i'm kind of i want to play knight c8
or do i
it's a good okay so yes this i saw this
this is i think this is just the draw
on 879 is going to get to f6 but that's
that's about it
white cannot really win that position
and but uh oh wait what am i doing i'm
supposed to be playing for a win oh my
god i'm so stupid
oops that's argentina oops sorry
argentina oh my god my bad
i mean argentinian flag and israeli flag
is are kind of similar looking now
what am i imagining things here i might
be
sorry
probably contemplating f3 but then i
have rk5 so i mean at least i'm safe and
okay
f3 did happen okay
all right so my opponent is not
is not liking a
a draw
obviously
so if my opponent is not working a draw
how about i also don't
how about i also don't like it draw
but i just need to be sure i don't lose
somehow because okay let's i mean we're
playing the song like
we're playing this this is this is
happening
this is so happening takes
uh okay takes there there
yeah let's do this go here
can i win this though like it's going to
be so tough to win this
it's
yeah he's just
just wants to draw or is this or am i
missing something here
go back
he just wants to draw no but why
it's so stupid
i don't want to draw
but like i did it to myself right like i
can't yeah i have to
dumb
yeah this is
i mean but that's that's what it takes i
mean that's not what it takes that's
what it leave that's what what happens
when you play when you play um
when you play carol when you play a safe
line of cara i mean at this point i may
as well just try to flag him but no yeah
it's
i'm i'm okay i can only lose if i let's
say go here and and go for this kind of
position i think i think the only thing
that can happen is me losing because he
has
he has a connected passer on e5 and it's
it's way easier for him to push so even
though he has only
about 20 seconds in his clock and i have
over a minute but yeah
um boring game all i can say is really
really boring game
it just shows you that
i guess doesn't matter i mean okay carol
is cara
has the potential of being a really
boring opening but that's that's that
all depends on how and what line your
opponent chooses
you're right i'm so stupid danish you're
correct see wow this was this was my
chance right here
yeah you're right i would have probably
won the game if i had a yeah had i seen
this
upsetting but once again
at least i didn't lose so i still i'm
still holding a chance for something
right i'm
not not for much but for something i
i just need to win the next game
and maybe i can like
sneak away get into a shared third place
and stuff
i'm gonna be i'm gonna get pushed back
by the people who are who are about to
win with seven and a half and i'm pretty
sure will be many of those
keep rolling yeah this is this not no no
joke this is my best attempt in title
tuesday
no no no
no just one one more to go danish just
one more
i have eight out of 10 and there is 11
games
i went one in a row yeah i'm gonna try
my best to win one game in a row
it's gonna be tough but i'll manage
let's see
unless i play hicaro in which case it's
going to be very hard to win one in a
row
but if i play literally anyone else i
think i have my chances are pretty
decent
oh is nemsco also playing in title
tuesday
uh she
her streams title reads late to title
tuesday
lol
okay so
can you wait join
entitled tuesday is it even possible i
don't know
once again i haven't
haven't really played
in it for quite some time so i don't
know how it works oh let's see so i'm
yeah i'm gonna be passed by these two
people and
and
then
yeah so yeah i just yeah so literally i
just need to win the next game
nobody else can pass me if i win the
next game i have i have a good shot
i'm actually going i'm going to be i'm
going to be playing up probably against
uh valerio spiridov
who is a national master from russia but
apparently he's a god-like blitz player
if i play him this is probably my
biggest chance ever if i get to if i get
to play him next game i'm going to be
white as well
obviously it doesn't mean that they
cannot lose
oh we have um we have
rook and bishop versus rook
oh thanks for the support where you see
i'm trying i'm trying
my black should survive right this they
didn't know the setup
yeah
consistency sound still works i believe
and roxy style is good too
now kane is going to flip with the rook
and okay it's going to go to e7 yep
all right so
amin knows his his end games
he's not too fast you usually have he
usually had his number on board got you
and god should danish all right
but obviously it's i mean it's that's
what it seems like it's gonna happen
right because i'm i'm i'm top i have the
best uh the best tie breaks among the
eight eight pointers so i'm supposed to
be the one going up
but maybe they do it so that whoever is
higher rate is going to go up in which
case you know there's a whole bunch of
people who are who are higher rated than
me
you never know
no matter what happens i'm happy with my
today's performance and all that while
commentating on stream imagine me i was
playing title tuesdays
by myself without like without streaming
and i wasn't doing well but maybe oh
maybe that's maybe that's what i'm
supposed to do i'm supposed to play
title tuesday on stream that's how i win
i think i just cracked the system okay
draw by 50 move rule let's go
we have that's it right we have
yeah so i'm sharing six i need to win
the next game and then
okay didn't happen but i'm playing a
candidate master
so i need to win still
let's go
very strong candidate master from india
very strong let's go
knight d7 that's not a move is it
sorry guys i need like full
full concentration mode right now
i'm pretty sure i'm better it's just the
question is how much if it's enough for
me to win
knight it just keeps jumping around like
a madman
i have d6 at some point like here for
example if b6 happens i have d6
even here d6 like what what does what
does black do against this
he does that really takes takes
this is over right
like i promote
bishop e69 b6 and bishop e69 b6 rogue d8
take stroke d6
gg
i mean
this this is probably history for me at
least this might be the first i think
this might be the first time i
even if i don't get into the top three
even if i don't get into top three first
of all whenever if if the if this if the
third place share is going to happen i
don't know i'd know the system maybe i
should maybe i'll have to play tie
breaks or they will do the darmageddon
match against somebody who's who has
shared surplus with me or maybe maybe
it's just going to take tie breaks and
give me the third place but whatever
happens
obviously we just share money
is that is that it we just share money
it's going to be like it's going to be
an obviously non-existent price but
doesn't matter
does not matter i haven't lost a single
game
entitled tuesday
and i got it i'm pro i'm i probably
guarantee myself top three
thank you arius yeah this was
my opponent didn't know
didn't know the um
i didn't know the line this
23 dollars
great performance thanks i could
probably do better not gonna lie if i if
i keep if i keep playing boots and if i
keep streaming playing bullets like
consistently i think i can do better
but yeah this
uh thanks arco dipto thank you for uh
everybody who
who are here supporting me that's that's
great help
you guys are the reason for why uh for
why this happened i'm not even okay
first of all we we we shouldn't we
shouldn't say anything in advance
because maybe i won't even get any
prizes but
if my calculations are correct then
um
how many people are service eight and a
half out of ten so okay so here jeffrey
versus wonderful time so we can even
share first if you if we get really
lucky we we gonna share first
because then
yeah so this guy needs to lose his white
oh my god he is losing that's insane
he's gonna lose even if he draws
did you hurt your hand by playing chest
to heart no my finger got fractured
while i was playing basketball so i
played basketball about a month and a
half ago and uh
actually was my good friend and who is
also a chess streamer japanese tutor jt
his name is charlie he's a really nice
guy
he uh he he flew over to saint louis for
for for the weekend to to just kind of
spend spend time with me and then we
played basketball that was my second
basketball uh of my entire life a second
basketball game of my entire life and uh
and i got really unlucky the ball
ricocheted off of the floor right into
my right into my ring finger and yeah i
didn't go to doctor immediately because
because gt told me that you know sprains
and and and and and stuff happens like
all the time
can i dunk no i can barely make it i can
make him i can barely make two pointers
like i'm really bad
you're tired yeah so if this so i just
need okay so what needs to happen is
this game needs to end in a draw this
game needs to end in a draw
if these guys draw
no joke
i'm sharing first
but i'm going to be probably going to be
wait what about hikaru is he car playing
still hikaru is still playing okay so if
he car wins right he carries eight
no he has seven and a half he car lost
two in a row
oh my god he caught lost two in a row
wait i have a real chance i have a real
chance of sharing first
that's insane
this game needs to these guys need to
need to draw
if these guys draw i'm i share it first
and i'm going to be second on time
breaks by the share first
oh my god they draw they draw they draw
oh my god no way
oh my god no way and this guy can't win
right i mean this guy absolutely cannot
win he can only lose
hello ashford
this is crazy am i the luckiest person
in the world or what
thanks for the stream of my pleasure
arcadipto my pleasure yeah i'm glad you
enjoyed it like look at this this is
insanity i mean okay black can still
lose this
if if he gets like
greedy and plays rookie seven now i
think he can still lose
c6 interesting interesting attempt
okay but this this does absolutely
nothing though
just kh4
okay i really hope black doesn't like
lose this game this would be a tragedy
like honestly
like what is black trying to do like i'm
i'm super confused but i can actually
lose now like what
please don't lose like for the love of
everything that's
that's there please don't lose
just keep the yeah just keep the rook
there just keep the rope there
black is asking for king c3 is going to
happen d5 right d5 yeah
k2
k3
k2
k3
oh my god that shirt first place
i shared first place ladies and
gentlemen
and i'm second on time breaks whatever
hooray whoa that's a that's a long tie
three four five six seven eight nine
people so far
that's fire yeah that is fire that is
this is my my officially my
best
title tuesday performance ever i'm not
even sure like i
i thought i thought i could do better
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if i could do better than
this
i'm happy i'm very happy and i'm yeah
i'm honestly the i'm this is this is
some kind of sign from above i'm
actually only half a point behind
jeffrey my tape break is literally half
a point behind it's
uh it's uh you see i've never ever won
anything entitled tuesdays and and this
the first time i i stream a simple chess
club's twitch channel
i basically almost went first place
yeah second by half of that we have yes
second but half a tie break it's okay i
take it
it's okay you know i
i i haven't you know what what i'm more
what i'm more excited about that i
haven't lost a single game it almost
never happens it's blitz pieces are
flying you know like nobody knows what's
happening and yet i somehow managed to
to
to to keep the score clean without a
single loss that's
my you know my my my ego has been
has been has been really happy or my my
ego is very happy right now like it has
has been it is
but anyway i think that's yeah that's
that's me
i uh i'm gonna be
you guys will see me
way more from now on uh on saintly chess
clubs twitch channel i'll be
uh i'll be uh yeah
streaming from their studio and and
hopefully i can hopefully i can do okay
it's really hard to beat the score like
i don't know what am i supposed to do
like two to beat this
but yeah hopefully i can one day win
clear first untitled tuesday that's
gonna be the goal